bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans cette nouvelle vidéo où nous allons
faire le point concernant le film Black
Panther Wakanda Forever je ne sais pas
pour vous mais personnellement j'ai
adoré le film que ce soit sur le plan
visuel la bande-son ou même bas tout
simplement Namor que j'attendais autour
non le film est très riche nous avons
plein de choses à mentionner et puis bah
j'espère que la vidéo vous plaira
attention au spoil bien évidemment
écoutez si vous êtes prêt bah ne tardons
pas commençons la phase 4 du Marvel
cinématique Universe est désormais
terminé effectivement pour celles et
ceux qui ne le savaient pas Wakanda
Forever et le dernier film de la phase
une phase qui aurait été beaucoup
critiquée notamment pour ses longueurs
mais parfois aussi pour un possible
manque d'intérêt jugé par certains
cependant il ne faut pas oublier que la
phase 4 symbolise le renouveau de Marvel
Avengers endgame était la conclusion de
la saga de l'infini la conclusion des
trois premières phases du coup la phase
4 est avant tout là pour servir de
transition et amener petit à petit la
saga du multivers et si je me permets de
faire un point là-dessus c'est parce que
je trouve que Black Panther ou à Kanda
Forever symbolise et représente
complètement cette phase 4 à l'image
d'autres
œuvres récentes du MCU Black Panther
Wakanda Forever possède une forte
thématique centrée sur le passé
néanmoins c'est un outil pour prévenir
et amener l'avenir c'est pourquoi je
trouve que le film est très intéressant
pour terminer la phase prenons quelques
exemples Choury a énormément évolué dans
le film pour à terme épouser le rôle de
Black Panther mais c'est quelque chose
qui a pris du temps effectivement à
l'image de la phase 4 les vestiges du
passé ant notre héroïne que ce soit sa
liaison avec son frère Ted Chala les
traditions et autres légendes wakandaise
ou même tout simplement l'histoire du
premier film avec killmonger tout ça ce
sont des éléments du passé qui à
l'origine servait d'obstacles pour
souris mais qui à terme vont lui servir
pour évoluer et une fois en magazine et
lui serviront pour appréhender le futur
le symbole est vraiment fort quand on
relativise par rapport à la face 4 qui
sert justement de transition et de
réponse à ce qu'a amené les premières
phases maintenant que nous avons fait le
point sur le passé tournons-nous
maintenant vers l'avenir et sur les
nouveautés qu'a apporté le film Wakanda
Forever nous a introduit Riri Williams
alias iron Hart à l'écran et je trouve
qu'on retrouve pas mal d'anciennes vibes
par rapport aux précédents films Marvel
ou subtilement de nouveaux personnages
viennent s'intégrer dans l'univers en
étant des personnages secondaires de
l'oeuvre un peu comme avec Falcon à
l'époque dans les films Captain America
bref comme vous avez pu le voir rire et
Williams est une jeune femme qui marche
un peu dans les traces de ton marque
concernant la technologie comme dans les
comics nous retrouvons son fameux garage
où elle effectue ses expériences nous
retrouvons également la mort de son père
avec notamment la voiture qui lui sert
d'héritage ou tout simplement la trace
de la technologie de Stark qui lui a
permis de concevoir sa propre armure le
seul élément qui change vraiment dans le
film par rapport au comics c'est le cas
de ces études dans le sens où
normalement Riri est dans une université
classique des États-Unis alors qu'ici
elle est dans une université créée par
le Wakanda c'est un bon élément de
réécriture qui permet de répondre aux
souhaitschala dans le premier film celui
d'ouvrir le Wakanda au reste du monde
d'ailleurs on retrouve également sa
liaison avec le Wakanda puisque Riri
dans les comics partagera un bout
d'histoire avec Shuri et à terme elle
aidera beaucoup le Wakanda dans la
conception de vaisseau ou autre
technologie bref ce qui est intéressant
par contre c'est que contrairement à
Namor Riri n'a pas eu de véritable orig
story dans Black Panther Wakanda Forever
nous avons eu simplement des petits
éléments qui entourent le personnage je
pense que c'est parce que Marvel
conserve vraiment de côté tout ce qui
entouré pour sa future série prévue à
l'avenir et qui se déroulera du coup
juste après Black Panther Wakanda
Forever étant donné sa découverte du
Wakanda et sa liaison avec Choury il y a
des chances pour que nous retrouvions
ces éléments dans sa série qui sait
peut-être que le Wakanda comme ils l'ont
taquiné dans le second film aideront
Riri à concevoir sa véritable armure où
elle deviendra iron Hart mais voilà à
voir ce qu'ils feront avec le personnage
peut-être qu'il l'intégreront à la
future équipe des Young Avengers pour
continuer il va bien falloir que nous
parlions des Atlantes et du coup de
Namor et bon sang qu'est-ce que je
l'attendais la mort c'était vraiment ma
grosse attente concernant le film et
sincèrement je n'ai pas été déçu alors
je ne vais pas vous mentir il y a plein
de choses à dire concernant la mort et
les Atlantes il y a eu beaucoup de
changements et de réécriture et je pense
qu'il est intéressant de se pencher sur
tout ça pour comprendre ce qu'ils ont
voulu faire pour le MCU alors concernant
les Atlantes en eux-mêmes nous
retrouvons bien évidemment bah le
royaume d'Atlantis un l'océan Atlantique
on retrouve également bah à tout ma et
Namora qui sont des Atlantes plutôt
connues mais bref ce qui va nous
intéresser c'est plutôt l'Origin story
apporté par le film dans les comics les
Atlantes sont issus d'une branche de
l'humanité qui s'est développée dans
l'océan en gros vous connaissez tous
l'évolution de l'homme avec les
australopithèques l'Homo erectus et
ainsi de suite et bien les Atlantes
c'est la même chose mais tourner vers
l'océan il est dit que dans l'air
primitive des mammifères se sont
développés dans l'océan et à terme cela
a donné naissance à des hommes qui
seront désignés comme l'homo mermanus et
tout comme les hommes de la surface ces
derniers ont évolué ce sont adaptés puis
ce sont modernisés jusqu'à atteindre un
savoir avancé une technologie également
avancée etc etc on ne va pas se mentir
c'est un petit peu bancal pour l'univers
du MCU et je suis plutôt satisfait qu'il
n'est pas adapté ça pour le film au
contraire je trouve que l'origine story
amené par Wakanda Forever permet
d'apporter quand même une petite part de
de mystique un petit peu de légende tout
comme avec le Wakanda en fait et leur
histoire en réalité cette origine story
permet de relier les Atlantes et les
wakandés et du coup nous montrer leur
similitude l'un et l'autre ont accès aux
vibranium l'un et l'autre sont des
peuples à l'origine secrète ils ont une
plante qui modifie leur état bref tout
est fait pour qu'il se ressemble
néanmoins un point que je trouve
intrigant et que j'aimerais souligner
c'est le cas du savoir atlante Marvel a
fait le choix de conserver cet aspect
traditionnel du peuple cependant je me
dis que l'on ne sait pas encore tout de
ces derniers effectivement les Atlantes
sont censés être avancés énormément sur
la technologie surtout qu'en plus ils
ont accès aux vibranium c'est une petite
aparté mais peut-être que ce sera
développé et amené dans de futurs
projets bon et concernant n'amorent plus
particulièrement j'ai plein de choses à
vous dire déjà il y a deux belles
références au comics que j'aimerais vous
partager tout d'abord c'est le cas de la
longévité de Namor on nous dit dans le
film que na mort est âgé de plusieurs
siècles par rapport à sa condition je
pense personnellement que c'est une
référence au fait que Namor fait partie
des tous premiers personnages créés par
Marvel sous leur nom de l'époque timely
publications effectivement Namor a plus
de 100 ans si l'on se réfère au comics
et il est encore aussi vigoureux qu'à
l'époque et l'autre référence c'est sa
scène d'introduction parmi les Atlantes
en fait cela reprend le tout premier
comics una mort apparaît à l'époque dans
Marvel mystery comics numéro 1 Namor
croise deux plongeurs reliés à un navire
en train d'enquêter sur la dépouille
d'un bateau le prince atlante se sentant
menacé va attaquer les plongeurs puis
les tuer et il va finir par détruire le
navire d'où proviennent ces fameux
plongeurs mais désormais
intéressons-nous plus particulièrement
aux personnages et à ce qui le composent
dans les comics Namor est un personnage
dont la principale source de
détermination est la vengeance en gros
dans l'histoire d'Atlantis l'humanité a
plusieurs fois causé de nombreux dégâts
à la civilisation sous-marine sans le
savoir à cause notamment des cellules
nucléaires ou autres arsenaux et du coup
à maintes reprises Atlantis a été
détruite et beaucoup d'habitants étaient
tués comme il nous l'a été expliqué par
la mère de Namor la princesse fenne son
fils est en quelque sorte un élu des
Atlantes qui va conduire son peuple vers
la justice envers les hommes de la
surface Namor a pour signification le
fils vengeur sauf que dans Black Panther
la Kanda Forever Namor n'est pas dans
une optique de vengeance au contraire il
est limite plutôt dans une optique de
conquête et c'est là que c'est
intéressant car la vengeance n'étant pas
d'actualité ou du moins pas encore mais
nous allons y revenir et bien Marvel a
fait le choix de développer
principalement un autre trait du
caractère de Namor pour le présenter et
c'est sa détermination la mort est un
personnage se situant à la lisière entre
les super-héros et les vilains il est en
quelque sorte une entité grise une sorte
d'anti héros et tout cela cela
s'explique notamment du fait que Namor
est sans pitié comme annoncé dans le
film où ils ont modifié la signification
de son nom Namor veut dire le fils sans
amour mais il ne faut pas le prendre
dans le sens le fils qui n'a pas reçu
l'amour de sa mère etc non c'est plutôt
dans le sens où Namor est sans
compassion sans pitié Namor est
quelqu'un qui n'a pas peur de se salir
les mains si il est obligé de le faire
il n'hésitera pas à commettre les pires
atrocités si c'est nécessaire il est
capable de tout si à ses yeux c'est
juste prenons l'exemple de Secret Wars
que je trouve très parlant Secret Wars
c'est l'événement ou les Avengers vont
subir ce qu'on appelle des incursions
c'est-à-dire en gros que leur univers et
un autre univers d'une autre réalité
vont rentrer en collision et si rien
n'est fait et bien les deux univers
seront détruits sauf que du coup la
solution pour se sortir de ce problème
c'est d'annuler l'univers d'en face pour
assurer la survie de son propre univers
mais accessoirement cela veut dire
ôter la vie de milliards de milliards
d'êtres vivants qui n'ont rien demandé
étant moralement atroce les Avengers
vont se dégonfler à plusieurs reprises
au point même de finir déprimer et c'est
là qu'un personnage va briller c'est
Namor pour Namor facile à survie des
Atlantes signifie détruire d'autres
univers alors soit let's go sans aucune
hésitation Namor est prête à le faire
pour que son peuple puisse prospérer et
c'est quelque chose que l'on retrouve
dans le film nachia quand elle va tuer
une atlante pour libérer souris et Riri
Namor va directement intervenir et
envahir le Wakanda jusqu'à tuer la reine
du pays parce qu'une atlante a trouvé la
mort bref nous aurons l'occasion de
reparler de l'essence même du personnage
puisque sachez le je vous prépare un
pourquoi Namor et si unique cela devrait
sortir dans les prochains jours bon et
du coup qu'attendre de la mort pour la
suite et bien je pense que maintenant
que l'introduction du personnage a été
effectuée nous allons pouvoir désormais
rentrer dans du concret pour l'avenir de
Marvel effectivement je pense que la
prochaine étape et la révélation du
peuple Atlant au monde de la surface en
fait la proposition de chouri de le
secret de l'existence du royaume
d'Atlantis et de tout faire pour le
protéger c'est une excuse pour moi afin
de mettre Namor et les Atlantes de côté
pour le jour où Marvel voudra clairement
les faire revenir car en soi si on
relativise Namor n'attend que ça d'être
découvert même s'il prétend le contraire
il souhaite conquérir le monde de la
surface et si on prend en référence les
comics c'est un petit peu la prochaine
grande étape de la mort sa révélation au
monde et son combat contre l'humanité en
fait je me dis qu'à tout moment il peut
y avoir un accident où les humains
causent des dégâts au royaume des
Atlantes et à tout moment Namor est prêt
à se venger c'est clairement quelque
chose qui fait partie du personnage un
simple petit pas de travers et il est
capable de tout détruire d'ailleurs le
fait que Namor affirme que le Wakanda
n'a pas d'allié à la fin du film cela
peut sous-entendre que Atlantis quant à
eux sont prêtes à s'ouvrir et escalier à
d'autres nations ou d'autres entités
pour émerger du du coup alors défaites
face au Wakanda alors on ne peut pas se
baser véritablement sur quelque chose de
solide pour le moment mais je vois
potentiellement pourquoi pas deux cas de
figure déjà la présence accrue de
Valentina a les gradé fontaine dans
Wakanda Forever encore une fois le
personnage est présent et sert encore
une fois à nous montrer à quel point
elle est importante et au milieu de tout
ce qui se passe comme vous le savez
Valentina va à terme nous proposer
l'émergence de l'équipe des thunderboltz
et bien je me dis que pourquoi pas Namor
pourrait un jour s'allier à eux ce qui
me fait penser ceci c'est que le jour où
va apprendre pour l'existence des
Atlantes elle sera forcément intéressée
pour les rencontrer et les faire
travailler pour elle elle est
constamment en quête des entités les
plus puissantes du monde pour former ces
troupes et puis il ne faut pas oublier
que les thunderbolds composer
majoritairement d'anti-héros ou autre
entité grise Namor et quelqu'un comme ça
donc qui sait mais également cela
pourrait être pourquoi pas l'avènement
de ce que vous attendez tous la célèbre
alliance de Drum et de Namor déjà c'est
un duo très connu des comics ils ont pas
mal travaillé ensemble étant donné que
Namor est prêt à s'allier à une autre
nation pour confronter le Wakanda et
bien Doom est le leader de la laspberry
un petit pays européen donc cela
pourrait coller mais surtout Namor de
par le vibranium pourrait en fournir au
Docteur Fatalis en échange d'une
alliance pour confronter le Wakanda et
puis soit dit en passant Fatalis en
profiterait pour découvrir les secrets
de ce pays en plus dans les comics Namor
et Doom ce sont déjà alliés pour
confronter le Wakanda bref enfin
toujours sur Namor et pour terminer sur
lui il va quand même falloir parler de
la grosse réécriture le concernant et
qui change pas mal de choses c'est
l'apport de son côté mésopotamien comme
dit dans le film ses ennemis l'appellent
Namor mais son peuple l'appelle
coucoulcan ce qui est intéressant c'est
que coucou le canne existe dans
l'univers Marvel des comics c'est un
dieu maya et il est souvent confondu
avec Kenza coalt en fait bien évidemment
la porte de cette mythologie c'est avant
tout pour mettre Black Panther et la
mort sur un même pied d'égalité le
Wakanda de par le Black Panther c'est un
peu l'élu de la déesse baste qu'il
vénère et du coup bah c'est la même
chose de l'autre côté avec les Atlantes
mais cette fois-ci avec coucou le CAN
sauf que point intéressant Moonlight
nous a apporté ce concept d'Avatar des
dieux Mark Spector et l'avatar de koncho
le dieu égyptien de la Lune et de la
vengeance et il n'est pas le seul à être
un avatar par définition c'est un peu le
même principe avec le Black Panther et
et ce qui voudrait dire que Namor serait
lui aussi en quelque sorte l'avatar d'un
Dieu et c'est vraiment quelque chose que
je veux souligner car déjà même avant la
sortie du film je me posais la question
est-ce que Namor ne devrait pas être
l'une des entités les plus puissantes du
MCU quand on relativise le personnage
réunit cet aspect d'Avatar de Dieu en
plus de cela il est un atlante et les
Atlantes sont des surhumains en termes
de physique mais cela ne s'arrête pas là
puisque Namor est aussi un mutant de par
ses petites ailes qui lui permettent de
voler et d'ailleurs petit trivia mais
nous voyons des dieux Mayas dans Thor
love and thunder ce qui pourrait appuyer
cette idée d'Avatar mais bref je voulais
juste amener cette question et cette
thématique sur le tapis vous en faites
ce que vous voulez pour conclure il va
falloir que nous parlions de la
divulgation du fils caché de tes Chala
et nachia l'arrivée de Toussaint alors
si on essaye d'expliquer son existence
nachia et techala ont un enfant vers les
événements d'Infinity war puisqu’après
le roi du Wakanda a disparu pendant 5
ans puisque la moitié des êtres vivants
avait disparu à cause du snap de Thanos
du coup bah l'enfant aurait grandi
durant cette période maintenant si nous
nous tournons vers les comics et bien
cela fait un petit peu comme pour Thor
et love dans Thor love ander en fait tes
Chala n'a jamais vraiment eu d'enfants
dans les comics en revanche il existe
une réalité alternative un autre univers
un peu comme Thor où ce dernier a eu un
fils avec sa femme Storm dxmen Azari
mais si on relativise rien ne rapproche
les deux enfants tout ça est un
personnage inédit créé pour le MCU
personnellement je trouve qu'il est le
symbole parfait pour la phase 4 le petit
garçon possède le même nom que son père
techallah désormais un vestige du passé
mais il est voué à grandir et devenir
une entité unique pour l'avenir du MCU
dans tous les cas au son prénom et de
son potentiel avenir je pense que Marvel
souhaite re-développer un nouveau Black
Panther pour le MCU non pas que Shuri
n'est pas intéressante elle a beaucoup
de choses à faire et à nous raconter
mettez de Chala et Shuri bien qu'il
partage le même costume ne sont pas les
mêmes personnages il est fort possible
que Marvel souhaite continuer le
développement du personnage de teachala
des comics et le feront à l'avenir par
le biais de tout ça
enfin voilà je pense que nous allons
nous arrêter là j'avais plein de choses
à vous dire concernant Black Panther
Wakanda Forever j'espère que ma vidéo
aura été assez complète et j'espère
qu'elle vous aura plu surtout bien
évidemment je ne vous ai partagé que mes
impressions et mes idées à vous de me
dire en commentaire vos ressentis je
suis très curieux de vous lire je suis
très curieux de voir ce que vous avez
pensé du film tout simplement en
attendant écoutez bah n'oubliez pas le
petit pouce bleu qui me soutient
énormément n'oubliez pas non plus de
vous abonner à la chaîne et on se
retrouve prochainement pour de nouvelles
vidéos allez c’était argorock que la
lion hard soit avec vous ciao tout le
monde
[Musique]